hi everyone it's Jerry playing another
rapid game
for the playlist improve your chess
rating this is video number three
let's start with E4
opponent's rating is 17.25 for this game
Sicilian Defense on board
okay
nothing complicated
useful move Knight F3
not interested in any closed Sicilian
type ideas and playing with the f-pawn
so I don't mind obstructing my F Pawn
right away
so this is a flexible move one of the
first thoughts that crosses my mind
um well it's flexible with
the bishop
it could still be deployed along this
diagonal
no D6 to interfere with this bishop at
the same time and E6 is interfering with
the light Square Bishop I don't have any
concern really of a pin one day against
my knight now that E6 is in
and from here I think I probably just
want to play
right in the center
open Sicilian
I'm expecting the capture as soon as the
duo is there
and I pretty much have to take with the
Knight
taking with the queen trying to develop
a new piece is asking for trouble
so Knight C6 is very sensible here
immediately challenging my knight
first move I'm considering is just the
capture
and I would expect black to take towards
the center
otherwise Black Will Go On castled
so
some other move besides Knight takes
Knight
is just to continue developing
if Bishop to B4 in that position
I believe I'm a move I have there is
Knight to B5
which defends my knight on C3 and also
eyes up the weakest Square in Black's
camp on D6
I'm gonna go for that
we'll see what black comes up with
so for now I'll just maintain the
tension
I'd be happy to see Knight takes Knight
get to recapture and develop a new piece
Queen is really well placed in that
position and she can't be kicked away
so easily
there are long-winded approaches
but
it's gonna take some time so I could
always revisit this capture I wonder
about maybe capturing at this moment
or still carrying on with development
says the weakest Square they are ruling
out multiple piece jumps from B5
both Knights Bishop
the bishop really isn't the
invasive piece if any it'd be a knight
since it highs up D6 so
what am I considering here
you can continue to develop
Bishop to E3
although of these two pieces
I think I think maybe I want to go with
my light Square Bishop first I don't
know how many options it really has
so if I consider these squares I can't
go to D3
drop the Knight and if I go to C4 I'm
probably asking for C excuse me for B5
one day
it's not so stable on C4 so if I'm going
to make a bishop move it would be to E2
um I think I want to keep some
flexibility with my dark Square Bishop
kind of playing it where
you know maybe I want to first see where
their dark dark Square Bishop goes
before making a commitment with my dark
Square Bishop
I think I'm going to go for that
and Bishop to E2
not Super Active but at least stable
all right
when is Black going to come up with now
if Knight to F6
that's when I could consider
a little more closely the capture so we
might see this now
capture and then
a push
and the stability of the Knight
is immediately in question
so
yeah
I think I want to go for this
and I would expect to take towards the
center still
and then E5 Knight D5 now
this is one of those proceed with
caution I did have an over the board
game
when I was a much younger player
where
I went for this capture and push while
this Knight was still on V1
and I ended up falling for Queen A5
check and I simply lost a pawn right out
of the opening
but that's not there in this position
because my knight is already on C3
Queen A5 is not hitting with Chuck
so this is a candidate move to be sure
I think I do want to run in for this
idea to push the Knight around now how
might black follow up after this this
and Knight to E4 because this is this is
my my big plan
to tuck my knight right behind the pawn
and start to work on that D6 Square
I think black could continue with Queen
C7 putting pressure on the pawn that
would be sensible
I do have F4 in that position to defend
it's a little bit weakening E3 in
particular but I do have it covered
and nearby
I do have a C4 move possibly
but also watch out for Bishop checks
yeah I don't know about C4
Bishop B4 check could be bothersome
even so I think I do want to go for this
Knight takes Knight and then E5
hmm
some other move to consider
I don't think this pin is anything great
it's immediately questioned or broken
I'm gonna go for the capture
expecting takes towards the center and
then E5
this is the consistent follow-up
so this guy's somewhat backward
also worth noting I mean after this
Knight E4 move there is the check
but she's not there hitting that pawn
directly
okay
there's even possibilities for a a pawn
sacrifice so I I should probably Express
that even if
like after Knight to E4 I think I should
put this on right now after maybe Queen
C7 I could maybe just Dive Right In I
give up a pawn I'm not winning material
with C4 trying to take advantage of a
pin tonight
because there are ways out with Queen B4
check
but it's a big piece this dark Square
Bishop if we take into account the
structure
this guy is not having the the greatest
time at the moment
how is it deployed now this is a
critical moment already for black I
think one lazy move
one one move that doesn't that's the
wrong term one one move that doesn't put
pressure on a soft point in my camp and
there could be some trouble for black
so this is a soft point
this is where black can give direction
to me and I believe should
this next move Queen C7 or maybe I don't
know these are ollies
very difficult moves to play so I think
this is
a step in the wrong direction this is
giving me a moment to breathe
I'm able to play
this C3 move
the bishop must go somewhere else
and now I'll be able to Castle
and eventually push this Knight away
and then dive into D6 so
it's really really close to some
strategically winning position this the
structure is very good here for white
I kind of value this Knight on e4 is
worth
it's a really strong piece tied in with
this Pawn
intersecting on the weakest Square in
Blacks Camp so let's begin
with C3 hang on for a moment let me do
it
a tactics scan where might I be
vulnerable this Knight is unprotected
um
this is the first time this move is even
crossing my mind
it does hit my knight but I don't think
that's anything wonderful in fact
he has some C3 Queen there I could even
play Queen D4 not only defending the
Knight but setting up a tactic of my own
check and then winning the queen
okay let's start with C3 there are no
tricks here my knight is a Defender as
well so
that's an important detail as otherwise
maybe there are these lines where
there's
you know the win of The Rook but
even in those situations that would
probably be good for white the two Pawns
in The Rook
they win two Pawns in a rook and give up
the two minor pieces
in a somewhat closed position like this
it's
usually better for the side with the
minor pieces
so is the bishop going to react or okay
so now it has abandoned
this diagonal
so this move is definitely
crying out to be played
however
I may want to First make use of
this square with my knight
and sneak in a
developing move
why not
Bishop G5
I don't know F6 I mean either way I'm
able go I'm able to
uh plan my night on D6 with check
hmm
this should be a winning position
so Black's going to be on Castle the
Queens are I've not seen the Queens
coming off anytime soon
just debating on whether or not I want
to play this or this
Bishop G5 F6
is that a move
takes Pawn takes I mean it should still
be good for me
the king is very weakened
um
maybe the Knight to D6
I'm gonna go I think I'm gonna go with
Bishop to G5 I think I like that one
yeah
let's get that one in there
also some some tricks that maybe try to
undermine my night support of the bishop
I do not think are working so for
example if
Knight takes pawn pawn takes Bishop
takes I'm not locked in
to taking here I mean I could
it's only the two pieces
for the piece but
I was even thinking I could play King to
F1 there but just grab it just chopping
away on C3 is cool
okay so now I'm pretty sure
I want to just hop in to D6
the more I'm looking at this I don't
know if I'm really so thrilled about my
bishop move
because this move could be really
irritating
hmm I wonder if I've misplayed this
I may have
said the king is on Castle this is this
is irritating now
undermining my night support I don't
wanna
I do not want to give up my night for
the bishop but maybe what I could say
here is
mission accomplished with my knight fall
back to C4 defend my Pawn pressure on
the bishop
takes takes takes
and Bishop to D2
they might get three pawns but
they'd be giving up
their big dark Square Bishop I think I
want to play Knight to C4
yeah
okay Knight C4 F6 I think was going to
be strong so
the
the majority of my attention is
is really on these two pieces though
they're not in my house but they're the
closest thing to being in my house
so this is a big Square that's been on
my mind
these squares right here weak points D6
E5
one move out from castling
really like to get that move in so they
are going for this idea
Okay so
we're going to take although
I may even have something better I mean
this is
this is a possible move Queen D2
let's see Queen D2
any night move other than Knight takes
Bishop I could take here and maybe even
on Knight takes Bishop
I could play Queen takes Bishop Queen
takes Queen Knight takes Queen where's
the Knight going
it is
able to sneak away by way of D2 that's
the only safe Square
so I guess I'm not gonna go for that
and instead just allow
this imbalance and what we're gonna
we're actually gonna see which imbalance
my opponent wants to go with
so I think I want to go here because I
still want to maintain the right
Castle
and we're going to see if they're going
to go after the Rook or the pawn
I think it is
definitely best to go after the pawn
rather than the Rook
but I'm expecting my opponent may take
the Rook here
giving more value to winning two points
five or three rather than just winning
the one point
I think either way I'm still doing well
because I'm expecting
to be able to plant a bishop on D6
and this will clog up the entire board
there's
I don't know the bishop stops any Rook
pivot from B8 I'm not sure how the black
Rooks ever
would find activity
um
yeah I think it's going to be a tough
road ahead now for black spent quite a
bit of time but I do like my position
okay so they are taking the Rook
the check is met with that one so let's
just recapture so these guys right here
versus The Rook
this should be really really good
I guess this guy's gonna be activated
like this
I have Bishop A5
that's something possibly
Bishop B4 check Bishop A5 maybe first
kick the queen from observing C5
and then I could play Bishop here I want
my Bishop on this square or maybe even
two minor pieces on these two
to completely dominate the queen side
this Knight is fantastic
I want a castle
I want to keep an eye on the checks
although castling isn't it isn't
necessary I mean this is this is
possibly a move
okay but let's not Castle this is not
I don't think this is the time to Castle
so I think I might be able to win
material
starting with Bishop A5 where does the
queen go
she goes to C8 lagna Fork
and if she goes to ba then I'm able to
play Bishop B4 check
I get my Bishop to D6 or maybe my knight
to D6
I think either way this is an excellent
start
and let's see where the queen goes
can maybe even
look to slip in with my queen to D4 the
dark squares
very compromised
okay
so
pretty much have to go here
okay
and now
to give the check or not
96.
if I get Knight D6 in and the my
opponent does not play C5 I'm able to
play here and then they can never play
that move because I have two pieces on
that
let's also look at this check check King
there
although maybe on the check they just
pitch a pawn and then look forward to
this move as well as some skewer
um
oh I have another move I'm just saying
Knight to B6 hitting the rook and
threatening a fork
well
okay I should be going for that then I
think
my knight as much as I like this guy I
think it's time to cash out I could win
the exchange with Knight B6
Queen has E5 defended
Knight B6 Queen C7
I think could be met with Queen C3
and then I'm defending my Bishop
threatening the rook and also
threatening Queen C5 and I get this
giant clamp on the dark squares
all right I gotta I gotta get a move on
here
under four minutes
this is the this is the main threat
so what do I think black should play I
think they should go with that one
yeah Queen C7
clean C7 Queen C3
and a rook move to maybe
I don't know
maybe there but no oh they're walking
right into the fork they were only
looking at this one
so I'm able to get the queen here
they might resign
now we're gonna play on it's fine too
okay let's just grab the material
I think when we look back it's going to
be the bishop B4 move where there's a
huge shift in the evaluation
and we're just at the point of making
things clean
up the material so let's castle for
starters
still focus on the basic stuff
completing development
I may not even want to allow this Pawn
to go any further
or
not maybe I don't even mind that
actually let's go Queen C3 looking at
this
I could ignore that
there's one possible way that black
could try to coordinate in my camp but
there are several ways to neutralize the
pressure
the main one is Bishop F3 just welcoming
exchanges releasing the pressure on G2
I don't want this Pawn to ever be
allowed to get to H3 so I'd be meeting
okay they resigned
I would be meeting H4 with H3
just typing a good game
okay let's go into
the analysis board on this one
and
oh the computer analysis is already done
yeah it was a it was a shorter game
but uh
yeah let's see the the dark squares is
the main takeaway with this one
so we do reach a critical moment
right around here so even be even before
this
Maybe
saying Queen C7 right now
yes Queen C7 is a very flexible move
with an ion the E5 Square I mean the
these moves here are securing this
follow-up advance and you know black
stays flexible not so not so quick to
deploy the Knight
has an eye on the E5 Advanced Queen C7
but Knight C6 right away Knight F6 right
away I could take E5
Knight D5 Knight E4 and now
I mean it is already liking my position
right here
so I was I was pointing out Queen C7
this is one of the moves but even better
apparently a C5 this is this is still
though an excellent position for white
so we need to go back
Knight F6 can we re consider that
already uh
an issue
link to F6
how many times has Knight F6 been played
38 times with the Masters database on
leeches
um I think it's a very comfortable game
after the capture and then the push
Neo
not the most current games there is one
in there right here from 2021 but this
grip right here is so valuable it's the
maybe a main takeaway from this
game
pawn and Knight
both coordinating on the the weakest
Square in Black's camp
it's a problem
at this stage for black so Bishop B4
does not
it isn't really an inconvenience
to why it's a convenient reply with C3
and yeah I mean the bishop would have to
go back here
this is a useful move
it's not like oh these these weakened
points after C3 or something black can
take advantage of the bishop would just
have to fall back so the check really
didn't uh accomplish too too much there
yeah it's really just a growing
Advantage at that at this point it's uh
I don't know if I
was torn between these two both are
still winning but
I think I would have gone for Knight to
D6
I had to do it again I didn't like
having to
drop my knight back like this oh it's
even saying Bishop H5 ah okay so that's
cool I could keep my knight right there
and I duck this idea and look to
reinforce my light my knight like this
possibly with
Bishop to G3 so let's say if F6 Bishop
G3 yeah
okay
so I had better here than the retreat
and the sacrifice isn't working what is
it saying take the pawn or The Rook
doesn't matter at this point so my plan
was to
take and then do something on the dark
squares
it's pointing out Rook C4 with the idea
is to get into D6 playing this straight
away is met with C5 I guess
yeah I'm not able to get where I
I'm not able to get to D6 so
take the rook and it's just a matter of
finding the clean approach
I was planning to meet Queen C7 Queen C3
it does like Queen C3 and then a rook
move I pointed out this but that's
asking for a skewer so Rook E8 and then
Queen C5 is what I had in mind
and then this guy never sees the world
if I maintain a piece here and I should
be able to
this guy never gets out
so classic tall Pond syndrome Knight C4
and you really just emphasize the
the dark Square control
these guys can never move
and so this guy never sees the world
okay
at the end of the day they missed the
the main threat there and I got the
queen just a couple more moves
okay I think that's gonna do it for this
video at the end of the day
94 accuracy 86 percent for my opponent
Feel Free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comment section
below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye